it's okay guys ste tested it right you
did tell me that it's by the way I came
back positive for everything every
single day it like they say it takes
around three days to get the results but
I was less like I was sure I would they
saw it in the blood and that day I got
tested positive for things I have no
one's even heard of before but you know
what you know why it's okay guys cuz
everything is awesome no I just use your
toilet like that's not okay this is
Sally and case you guys don't recognize
her here's a clip I definitely feel like
she's exaggerating never mind
you should probably go hide in a cave
I'm running right and I'm Jerry and I'm
sad welcome to reasons to see we give
you reasons to see movie I have no
parents
Bertie's didn't see number one animation
cinematography directing writing no
parents okay guys so we just saw the
lego movie and holy mother of god what a
film honestly right off the bat one of
my top 10 favorite movies of all time
yeah I really love this movie I felt
like a kid again I was I was so happy it
was just so much fun I thought about
when I would step on Legos hey it's just
incredibly immersive it's the weird I've
never seen an animated movie where I was
that pulled in where I felt like I was
part of the world it's just incredibly
imaginative it's so immense and it
though I mean there are times I was like
did they read did they use real Legos
yeah it did for certain parts because
they credited live animators for at
least some of it everything worked the
way Legos worked like really and there's
like this giant cities of it and stuff
and the action scenes are [ __ ]
incredible
transformers man they really had the
presence of mind to make everything be
of that design it's like even things
like puffs of smoke or fire or water
ripples are all done the way they would
be with Legos I mean I love their
approach because they basically approach
this like what if we had to make a
stop-motion animation film but all with
Legos and a couple other you know found
objects that would be of that you know
yeah things that you would have found
whilst playing with LEGOs as a kid like
it's badass it's like it's badass same
time that in itself was brilliant just
the way that they did the whole entire
set which even if it was like all
animated it looked like Legos like it
looked like I can I can already tell
someone is going to try and make this
whole entire movie out of actual legos
this is the first movie where I feel
like I got legitimately nostalgic
because they started showing you know
the different kingdoms of Lego and I'm
like oh the castle guys and the pirate
guys an acht and like I had all these
things as a kid like now I'm really
flashing back I really want to play with
them again that's one of my favorite
things about this movie is when you
think about Legos there's look they make
Legos out of like
anything that comes out this movie takes
total advantage of the back end they
make a story work that's it makes sense
it's so entertaining like not just the
story is inventive but like oh yeah the
animation absolutely is is it's
overwhelming actually I couldn't keep up
yeah we were talking about the beginning
of the movie I mean because we watched
it 3d of course which is Chris ranches
but in the beginning I was just like
this is intense like my mind was on
overdrive I was like what's going on I
mean it was I got it it means easy to
get but it's kind of just like what's
going on it's an onslaught like it's
just unlike any kids movie you ever see
so it was kind of overwhelming yeah I
mean it's almost got like a Looney Tunes
sort of pace to it because it's so fast
and it is very loud and very vibrant and
that's another thing the film is
hilarious it's not like a funny movie
it's hilarious you know I got a lot of
respect for Phil Lord and Chris Miller
who wrote and directed this together
like those guys have proven a number of
times and especially with this movie
that they really know how to take
something that could easily be contrived
or could easily be just a cash grab and
they make something interesting and
clever and substantive out of it because
I really felt like this movie they
really thought back to the spirit of
creativity and imagination and all the
things that Legos are why you lately
yeah it feels like only a child could
have come up with this imagination which
is okay here's the thing I went in with
expectations for this movie oh okay
Legos like this is probably you know the
company trying to boost sales so they
just decided to make a movie so I wasn't
really expecting a lot to surprise me
with this movie I just thought it was
gonna be you know like a stupid you know
fun kids film it's up there with like
Pixar the way Pixar did up its reminder
the same type but I just mean the way
that it captures you and the way that
they just throw in a lot of different
morals and a lot of different things but
it's not cheesy it's actually like
really well done I thought it was so
well done especially the twist at the
end I was like how can there be a twist
in the leg oh yeah I mean they really
have the presence of mind to take it to
places you wouldn't expect a movie like
this to go oh we did that perfectly and
I'm just
I left the movie theater really just
proud of the fact that they pulled off
something like that because I hate the
biggest thing that I hate is when I
actually go to pay to see a movie and I
leave and I feel like the ending just
did not do the movie justice but this
one definitely blew me away which is
hard to do so
good job lego movie best way I describe
this movie that's word it's an
experience that's what it really is it's
a cinematic experience I can't really
picture it you know picture watching it
on TV and getting the same effect than
watching no it's like avatar it's one of
those movies you have to see in the
theatre not that I disagree but I feel
like this movie it is an experience and
you know definitely see on a big screen
but I think you would get just as much
out of it at home that childlike wonder
that they really do a good job of
communicating reason to see number two
the cast the comedic timing it was
perfect
the cast was just perfectly cast it's
actually perfectly cast you know like
Chris Pratt I always see him in
supporting roles ensure it's an animated
movie but he does bring this this guy to
life
yeah his voice is perfect for that part
and even you know I recognize Elizabeth
Banks when she popped up and she does a
really good job Liam Neeson dude that
was a great comedic turn for that guy
man Holly I really like how they just
opposed you know badass Liam Neeson that
we're used to with a completely
different like light and whimsical side
of him the Will Ferrell was great too
Will Ferrell who has to pull a lot of
different but a lot it has everything
and I like about him all in one move and
Morgan Freeman was funny like every
character was from Morgan Freeman funny
you know how can you go this movie
without talking about Will Arnett
Batman's in this film you see them in
the trailer and no it's not one of those
trailers or like they gave away all
about as best they did that is awesome
in this film yeah my favorite would have
to be I feel like Charlie Day should be
in every animated movie because he is
almost a cartoon character
and I love that about him they have like
moments that actually hit but it never
loses the funniness yeah I mean there
were times or I was like about to cry
over Lego but then I was like wait it's
the Lego but they still have Laurie but
they always you know bring in some some
funny scenes like there was an intense
scene at the end but they made it they
made it super funny it's great
well the great thing about that everyone
guys reason to see number three music
but this movie has a soundtrack it's not
a museum I know there's like one scene
where to compare it to frozen is fair at
all because that's a musical like frozen
go you to war tangled or you know
Aladdin Beauty they mean like any of
those movies you associate with being
animated like this isn't a musical like
those are musicals does that Broadway
yeah well everybody's awesome was a
musical number no it's a song it's a
part of the sound cool but when he first
sang it he was yeah see but it's not a
musical movies not happening one it's
better than frozen that's what it was
not comparable in any way other than
they're both in and whatever you're not
wearing a Batman shirt
you know hipster cred because only a few
people are going to recognize this that
makes you those lonely people music in
this film bomb diggity there's so much
like lions in these songs where you're
you know like when the movie was done
everyone was singing in the theater like
I don't want to quote it too much but
like okay there's this Batman song and
of course everybody's awesome that one
better get nominees you have no idea
what we're talking major to post it on
Facebook before anyone else in it
Ryan's consensus the lego movie is the
[ __ ] reason movies are made the lego
movie is the [ __ ] reason movies are
made kids i swore and you know what he
deserved the F word at the time
cherry its consensus yep I'm gonna have
to go reason movies remain the lego
movie is the reason movies are made yeah
I mean this movie just excels on every
level it's a ton of fun if you know
there are things to reflect on it's just
a great time and they really knocked it
out of the park
the reason to see this movie is because
everything is awesome alright guys
thanks for checking out a review for the
lego movie why don't you go ahead once
you're done with that come over here
click this button so you can see more
episodes of reasons and last but
certainly not least if you want to get
updated every time one of our awesome
[ __ ] videos is out subscribe with a
sh you remember that party it did good
job Sally doesn't she look like she
could be a Barbara Gordon Barbara Gordon
is the daughter of Jim Gordon Batman
works with Jim Gordon and she eventually
becomes Batgirl actually just said she's
back from The Mikado Gordon's daughter
said the casting director is watching
this knows look at her man
she'd be [ __ ] awesome I mean she's
like adorable or like a really badass
impossible you would be a great camp I
know you really would Kim Possible she
was hot dude I could totally do stuff
work impossible if I was like an
animated cartoon that was a cartoon
doing stuff for Kim Possible kids watch
Kim Possible you will have the classic
classic classic and man will you yes or
not